hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach now some of you have
said that I'm a big whiny baby but
that's not true but the others of you
have said that I've already passed of
the Slobodan slobber clockwork machinery
No I'm going in there I know all about
what's going on in there and I'm never
going in there ever pass hey hey hey
stop with the light show I'm going to be
just fine if you will shut up and let me
work why what happened did I get cut by
the did I get got by what's-his-face or
I got caught 5 radical Larry well did
that happen he just like appeared but I
thought he appeared in the other
direction but I am apparently then I'm
gonna be boned either way so let's look
for the burn note here it is let's go oh
boy
I love Larry's dimension of Horrors it's
my favorite place to be son of a monkey
Nutter think city can mix mess with the
likes of me oh wait I've already been in
here because yeah this is this is back
when I was ha that was new
shut up shut up you a-hole okay I don't
know what that was but did you see that
was it too quick for the camera to catch
maybe oh this is where the big swinging
balls swing across this little platform
here and tried to smash me into oblivion
like right now doc son of a [ __ ] mother
food well that was stupid and you're
stupid for doing it to me game not you
guys
you guys aren't anything but stupid
you're all smart and handsome and/or
beautiful depending on you who are you
they're all [ __ ] I don't have my glasses
I mean I don't have my goggle one of my
goggle glasses your nose bulge over here
this is important I want to see this
radical Larry well that sucked
oh good radical air you took me away
just as I was seeing a very important
part of this story when something new
and interesting was happening you're
such an a-hole
God does everyone hate radical Larry as
much as I do
because yeah you hear me talking about
you a little [ __ ] yeah you better run
away you better not mess with the likes
of me because I'm a super tough guy with
ten billion metric tons of muscle not 2%
body fat muscle all right let's just try
and find a way out it's not even gonna
pour him back to where I was supposed to
be I want to know what that was I wanna
know what was going on there
you're just an a-hole now you're just
running me in freakin circles all over
the place and I'm not gonna be able to
get back there and I'm not gonna be able
to do anything I'm just gonna be here at
Radio 50:53 oh this is red what is this
what is this everything's crooked I tuo
oh hey oh this is your throne
I remember this hey hey your mother your
mother okay I'm leaving now
[ __ ] [ __ ] your mother [ __ ] your mother
ah sorry sorry from my cursing everybody
I just thought that he needed to know
what I felt about him alright so anyway
I'm gonna try to get back I'm actually
gonna try to get killed in some regard
because I want to go back outside
because I want to be able to run away
from mr. radical Larry from his rather
uncertain
I'm just gonna make up big words to seem
like I'm smart come on idea big swinging
balls
I've never shied away from a pair of
balls it never mind I'm dead yeah I'm
dead just let me respawn that's all I
wanted OCP 71/4 has been showing up wait
hang on tolerance step okay never mind
then alright screw you radical Larry you
appear and then you go to hell you go to
hell you go to hell you go to hell and
you dad you go to hell and you dad I'm
just gonna go this way
Oh Roger nutters flubber dunkers flubber
nutters oh come on this is so unfair
ah he's much closer than I thought he
was he came in through it came from hi
well what the hell this is like what is
this radical Larry Central is this what
I'm supposed to be dealing with I gotta
lose him in the tunnels or something
earlier I just gotta get through here if
I could finally just find a way out it
wouldn't waste so much time there's
something interesting
where'd the damn burnt note in there it
is
last one when they do a 360 this is not
new radical error you're an a-hole and I
hope you know that help you oh hello
I remember this I just got to go through
this three times before you'll let me
out since you're so nice and so pretty
little pink tutu then I bet you we're
and you're angry that I walked in on you
as you were applying makeup yo whatever
did I get taller god I hope so
just leave me out or kill me or whatever
because you're a giant piece of douche
this way I'm guessing
oh no this light so it throne does it
it's gonna turn red yeah it turns red
okay getting out of here god I can
barely see everything's all wonky wobbly
I'm just wasting time and I'm just
wasting time precious precious time oh
this just goes to the weird room I need
to go to the weird room I need to go in
the exact opposite direction in order to
get to the big swinging balls in either
die or make it across by some weird
string of luck because I can't see the
balls swinging in front of my face I
just got to reach out and grab them grab
them rug grab them tight
well I was right in front of my face
okay let's wait for that to cross again
there we go okay now we go I can't
sprint so basically I'm left up to my
own devices okay I saw that let me stop
here okay I see it
ah pass come on if I did just kept
moving forward I would have been fine
this is this is a son of a [ __ ] this is
the baton definition of a son of a [ __ ]
and I've fallen through that you've
gotta be Omar alright you know what
hang on Oh clip on you gotta be joking
me
you know what you know what I'm gonna go
around yes he's there what the hell go
away I'm just gonna go this way till I
can't see you until you disappear just
going backwards till the music stops
where am I now
No
what a stroke of luck I can't believe
how great I am and let me just do
something else here quick can you go
away Jesus how much longer is he gonna
frickin follow me go away
stop being a giant a-hole what the hell
is there a despawn douche bag command
please tell me there's a despawn douche
bag command because this is unbelievable
he does not follow this far especially
when I'm flying through space wandering
like a bunny as I'm cooperating you
gotta be joking me
go away go to hell there's got to be a
despawn like how do I just
oh come on hey dick balls I'm a disabled
you Oh what that no it's a disabled Oh
disabled 106 all one word done are you
gone now
yes finally I'll rien a Boleyn and able
106 that way he's he's there but he's
not here where he's not supposed to be
god damn that was ridiculous all right
whatever
all ridiculousness aside he is a giant
pain in the ass and I don't want
anything to do with him ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever I can so
everyone ignore the fact that I cheated
they're just some of the annoyances he's
like gotta be the most annoyed what no
did they change that again you gotta be
kidding me I gotta go back out and then
back in this is unbelievable I am so
angry even though I'm smiling like this
is me in my angriest this is look oh
sorry
okay dear life it's just a pain into a s
ass pain in the ass ass
alright I'm okay I'm alright it's just I
guess now that I I need to put it on
very fine now because I don't know it
used to be it at first it was see if you
put it in very fine and give me the Omni
card then it changed if you put it on
fine and give you a step up each time
and that gave me a playing card
I don't what do you have for me
that's a MasterCard that is not what I
need this is not gonna help me at all I
am wasting my time and my life this is
the worst I hate everyone I hate
everything bye Hey oh goodness in the
world I am turning into another SCP good
god dang
I'll just pick up my card and be on my
way through the walls excuse me
no clip no clip on whoa whoa
[Music]
okay pass through that oh oh oh oh I've
done I've done bad where am where is
this where m is this okay that's the me
oh okay I'm just one off of where I need
to be okay ah here we go I was barely
off my target okay
ah no clip ah now we were officially
back to where we started when I started
this episode
god dammit I am going to stab someone in
the eyeballs preferably the SCP that's
coming up just here so get ready I want
to see what this is okay let's see
what's going on here hi
I don't know stop looking at him
[Music]
[Applause]
that's gotta be one of the freakiest
scps I've ever heard about like
seriously that whole deal is like
freaking terrifying to me just me to see
his face once and he will not stop have
you read the story if you haven't read
the story go out and read the story
because it's it's flippin fantastic oh
that was close
holy crap he's in here he's actually in
here walking around little is his face
let me look at the road no you can't be
here not you do not yo dope yo pump on
what the heck is the fuel pump for how
should I know I'm just a class d what
did they can do don't look at the ground
look at the Browns look at the grout
look at the rap that seem to be locked
why why
I need to go in that room oh he's just
in it weird you know in a in a different
dimensional way kind of reminds me of
this one he's just standing there so
creepy it's so weird I gotta get in that
room but he's blocking the way oh he's
going into the room oh my god I'm
running out of time he's just standing
there he's just standing there he's just
standing there I'm just gonna keep his
arm in frame
space wouldn't be so worried about okay
that's a good place to end it for now
sorry I didn't get much done there but
you did see at least one new rather
horrifying thing so he's walking around
in that room basically have two looked
like go through the room like yeah
looking at the ground so anyway yeah
really freaky just a tear or affine idea
horrifying ideas are the best I didn't
best start the monsters so anyway thank
you all so much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]